c'est le dernier poste de l'armée
malienne avant la ville de dia ben ali
cela fait cinq jours que l'armée
française a commencé son intervention au
mali au bout de cette route à 40
kilomètres dhia ben ali est tombé entre
les mains des jihadistes
ils ont envahi la ville et sa région
après avoir été repoussé par les forces
spéciales françaises
en guise de remparts environ vingt-cinq
militaires maliens bloquent la route
il contrôle tous les véhicules
et bien d'où la voiture la bon johnny
pendant quatre heures les militaires
méfiant tolère ma présence sans
m'adresser la parole et progressivement
les langues se délient
je vais apprendre qu il y a quelques
jours certains d'entre eux ont combattu
les islamistes à dia ben ali avant de
prendre la fuite
alors comment ça se passait là
on pas les détails mais rage va prendre
dans le détail l'offre
ils étaient trop nombreux
surpris par cette séparation
on s'est battu pendant deux jours on
n'avait même pas à manger
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
que dieu nous vienne en aide
que
vous avez pas
la réponse
oui
un moment d'égarement
pendant les deux jours où je resterai
dans ce checkpoint je ne verrai pas de
militaires français
les soldats maliens me donne
l'impression d'être isolé et dépourvus
de moyens sérieux les français mais ils
viennent de temps en temps ils sont
venus aujourd'hui
et là vous êtes tout seul il n'avait pas
de radio tout seul dans ce checkpoint
les militaires maliens contrôler les
civils qui fuient la zone depuis
l'arrivée des djihadistes mission
plusieurs milliers à faire ce voyage
exténuant commencé pour certains il y a
trois ou quatre jours les militaires du
poste de contrôle en profite pour
s'informer sur l'attitude des
djihadistes vis-à-vis de la population
ils empêchent les gens de sortir
les buts sont en vente libre
carol turley y en a des billes
avant-hier on a sauté de l'internet mois
la série le soir sur la pugnacité d'un
point les endroits sans cela on fuit à
temps mais il est déjà dix se servirait
de la population bloqués sur place comme
bouclier pour se protéger des
bombardements français made la katiba sa
fuite il
whittingham roi
les civils sont pour la plupart des
paysans ils ont tout laissé derrière eux
n'emportant que le strict minimum
ils arrivent à pied ou sur des véhicules
de fortune comme ces charrettes
donnez moi vos papiers et sauve à papier
on a fui la guerre précipitamment on n'a
pas de papiers bon attendez on est parti
en urgence dès que les combats ont
commencé on a fui
on n'a rien pu prendre on va dans la
région de ségou
concernant
c'est à 150 kilomètres d'ici je décide
de les accompagner pendant leur voyage à
13 sur une charrette
ils n'iront pas bien loin il abandonne
dans la ville la plus proche
c'est abdoulaye diarra qui organise le
voyage comment comment vous allez à
ségou alors il faut qu'on trouve un
autre véhicule pour aller à ségou
adoulaye voyage avec ses deux femmes et
ses quatre enfants
il accompagne aussi la famille d'un de
ses amis qui est resté à diabaly pour
garder le bétail et les cultures
finalement un bus arrive maintenant il
paiera 1 euro par personne
c'est beaucoup d'argent pour ces
familles de paysans alors que tout le
monde s'entasse dans le bus
la femme de l'ami d'abdoulaye est assise
à l'avant dans ses bras un nourrisson il
a quel âge ton enfant aujourd'hui la
trois jours et tu as couché ou quand on
a quitté le village j'ai eu mal au
ventre et j'ai accouché en chemin c'est
un garçon ou une fille
c'est un garçon
doué ce prêt à temps
on ne lui a pas encore donné de nom
le voyage durera huit heures je les
accompagne en voiture
en chemin nous croisons les forces
spéciales françaises lourdement armés
elles se dirigent sans doute vers le
poste de contrôle que nous venons de
quitter à 60 kilomètres d'ici ce sont
ces hommes qui ont empêché les jadistes
de s'approcher de bamako
le soir vers 6 heures c'est l'arrivée au
village
abdoulaye va retrouver une partie de sa
famille qui l'attend il est accueilli
par son beau père bonjour bonjour
comment ça va ça va bien alors comment
ça s'est passé
c'est la guerre mais qu'est ce qui s'est
passé exactement
un jour on a été réveillés par les
combats ça a duré plus d'une heure
la situation était vraiment mauvaise on
a décidé de s'en aller
que dieu nous aide à retrouver la paix
abdoulaye sa famille et celle de son ami
vont être hébergés au village le temps
que la paix revienne à dia ben ali ils
savent que plusieurs semaines plusieurs
mois peuvent s'écouler avant qu'ils ne
retrouvent leurs maisons et leurs terres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]